monsieur monory bonsoir je veux dire
qu'on est un petit peu perplexe ce soir
parce que là on vient de voir
bon il ya eu il y à la manifestation
aujourd'hui la grève s'est étendue et
puis alors ce soir monsieur devaquet
donc l'auteur du projet de loi de
réforme qui ne plaît pas aux étudiants
étaient à rmc où il a dit j'ai rencontré
reçu les étudiants de l'unef id et ils
m'ont proposé une analyse meilleure que
la mienne je trouve que c'est une
analyse pertinente et un amendement en
ce sens sera proposé à l'assemblée
nationale pour tous dit content de cette
année c'est une façon de procéder dit
monsieur devaquet à mon avis tout sage
on se demande pourquoi ça n'a pas pu
être fait avant long métrage crois aussi
toute heure donc vous avez annoncé la
grève
il y avait trois sujets principaux
auxquels vous faites allusion
et je me dis et je le répète tous les
jours que peut-être nous n'avons pas
fait assez l'information mais qu' il ya
une mauvaise information
le premier sujet l'un des étudiants sont
pas fondées et vous les 10 premières
show de la sélection il n'y a pas plus
de sélections qu'avant vous aviez des
que avant pour rentrer dans les facultés
n'oubliez pas qu'il n'ya pas plus de 30%
des étudiants qui rentrent en première
kikititi et termine en licence donc vous
avez déjà une sélection s'opère tout à
fait dans le premier cycle de
l'université et en fin de compte doit s
opérer avant ou après ou doit-on tenter
de mieux orienter
en fait la loi devaquet c'est pour mieux
orienter les jeunes vers ce qu'ils
peuvent faire mais tous les enfants
munis du bac pourront rentrer dans les
univers saignante et les hacker dit qu
au lieu d'avoir un barrage après la
licence elle sera après la maîtrise
puisque l'unef a proposé ça il accepte
on est prête à accepter des quantités de
choses pourvu que ça corresponde je
dirais à l'essence même à la philosophie
de la loi
deuxième aspect le les droits d'entrée
le sénat fait voter un amendement qui
peut aller dans une fourchette de had t
aujourd'hui c'est 400 francs minimum de
400 à 800 francs sait pas encore par
rapport aux universités des filles est
rangé chose de très important d'autre
part on peut aussi accompagner cela par
une politique de bourges pour les plus
démunis
troisième chose les universités pourront
avoir leur diplôme mais ça existe déjà
marianne lourd ce que je peux affirmer
soir c'est que le diplôme national n'est
pas du tout remis en cause
donc en fin de compte j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya une succession de malentendus
à l'entendre bien sûr parce que le
diplôme national existe et que avant la
loi devaquet le diplôme d'université
existe on n'invente rien on poursuit sa
milice lorsque ce projet de loi a été
évoquée en conseil des ministres est ce
que le président la république avait des
milliers réserve reçoit du tout les ages
du condamné les remarques qu'il a pu
faire à auxerre il faut pas non plus
extrapolé à partir des remarques du
président la réplique à auxerre mois il
se trouve que j'ai rencontré près de
république à sa demande y avait près de
moi j'ai pu discuter avec lui une façon
très décontractée de la poésie du
ministère j'ai pas eu l'impression aucun
moment qu'il était en d1 en je dirais
randy en difficulté avec la politique
que je vais étudier en vue un
encouragement tout cas je sais pas si
l'on vient à l'encouragement moi j'ai
entendu ce qu'a dit monsieur mitterrand
finalement c'est ce que je dis depuis
quatre ou cinq mois l'école pour tout le
monde les cols de qualité etc
certains ne comprennent pas ce que ça
veut dire l'école de qualité et moi je
suis tout à fait pour
alors je ne sais pas si c'était vraiment
compris comme un encouragement ça serait
dommage que le président la république
encouragerait grève parce qu'un chef
d'état n'a jamais le droit de faire ça
moi c'est quoi alors une présence de
l'enseignement public sur l'enseignement
privé mais non il n'y a pas de revendre
lancer vos pulsions d'enseignement privé
je crois que ces deux enseignements
peuvent vivre ensemble moi je suis tout
à fait pour les deux enseignements et je
crois qu'ils peuvent parfaitement bien
vivre côte à côte mais ce que je crois
c'est que vous savez il ya un problème
de société en ce moment les jeunes
vivent
je dirais dans une ambiance un peu
d'angoissé il est vrai que personne
c'est le lendemain fil pour avoir du
travail ou pas moi je me bats vraiment
je ne pense qu'à une chose depuis cinq
ans depuis six ans à l'avenir comment
peut-on résoudre le problème de l'emploi
des jeunes par exemple à l'université
nous aurons besoin dans les 10 ou 12 ans
environ 2 250 à 300 mille instituteurs
et professeurs
il faut que les universités ne fasse
savoir aux jeunes il faut qu'on sait
qu'il faut qu'on se prépare à ça et je
crois qu'en fin de compte il ya à la
fois une angoisse et une mauvaise
information qui se télescopent en ce
moment pour faire de la loi sur
l'exercice est quelque chose
d'inacceptable
il sollicitera la concertation tous
azimuts le bien sûr de moi j'ai toujours
été ou savez j'adore les jeunes je ne
vis qu'avec les jeunes je ne travaille
qu'avec les jeunes donc je suis tout à
fait ouvert aussi bien
à quai à toute concertation avec les
jeunes car à mon avis il n'y a
absolument aucun malentendu une famille
je vous remercie
baptême